Google clouds anthos help support
companies and modernizing their services
and hybrid in multi cloud environments
but what does the stack actually look
like and what use cases does it solve
join us as we talk to Arctic about how
they implemented a hybrid cloud
environment on this episode of stack
jack thanks so much for joining us Kyle
tell us a little bit more about what
Arctic does yeah thanks for having us
Arctic's is focused on services and
we're born in cloud and focus on helping
developers you can get code in
production and all the things that go
around that and most of the time we're
spending that with enterprises so
helping them you know solve that culture
condition problem of moving from their
old world to cloud and all this
automation and everything that comes
with it is we're helping enable them and
getting them to be successful so tell us
a little bit more about this specific
infrastructure yes so this particular
customer we worked with they have a
traditional application it's been a they
made it a micro services it's cloud
native it runs in GCP and gke and it's
very successful in that but they've got
customers that have challenges around
locality data residency things like that
so they may have to deploy in a region
where there isn't a Google cloud or they
don't have good network connectivity so
for them they've had to manage that in
the past of deploying homegrown
kubernetes environments in most places
and trying to manage them and trying to
keep them updated and patched and you
know it's a tough job to be able to
manage these things so they're looking
for a common experience and a way to
take all the automation and all the good
things they've done in cloud and be able
to apply that into their own Prem
offering and most importantly offer a
consistent experience that is easy to
support and then the custer's not
getting a lacklustre you know experience
just because it's not in cloud anymore
so it's that that's really what's given
them the agility to be able to do this
okay so if they've got their kind of
their home base in the cloud but then
they've got all these different
customers in different places and
there's no commonality between some of
those environments then as you said it's
a pretty difficult thing to manage I
hear that anthos kind of played a big
part in helping standardize this
environment so what does that actually
look like yeah so this customer was
leveraging homegrown communities in many
cases and when they saw anthos their
interest was could we take anthos in
that
reference architecture apply it into our
customer scenarios but leverage our
exact same CIC D pipeline all our same
helm templates all those charts that
we've been leveraging and deploy on
there without having to re platform all
their deployment every time so they
looked at that as a real game-changer
for them to be able to go to market and
solve some of these customer challenges
that they haven't been able to solve yet
so we started the project and built the
architecture around this we deployed you
know being more cluster in Berlin and
got that up and running and then it was
taking all the the lessons learning
cloud so they were using cloud build
they were using GCR they were using a
lot of those rapid cloud tools so really
all we had to do was get those artifacts
now into their private stack and be able
to deploy against anthos so you know
within a couple weeks we were able to
stand all this up put through
performance testing it was a real lesson
learned and the biggest impact was can
we take this common experience and make
this on Prem deployment looked just like
another deployment region that was the
real goal right so now they've got all
of these environments that are kind of
like offshoots of their core environment
but they all look pretty much the same
and then they roll out the code the same
way that we're kind of rolling it out
before but now it's easy to roll it out
to all of those yeah it really is that
perfect hybrid story because that's the
deployment region is the end state code
after it's tested that's where it's
going to run but they still have to do a
innovation and testing and put new
features in so that's where the cloud
comes in handy for them so they're able
to spin up clusters on demand and we
started looking at things like config
management for them and helping them you
know getify all that workflow but they
can spin up clusters on demand and UK do
all their testing tear it back down once
they get a release ready they can push
that release out to that on-prem
environment and it's all just through
standard automation framework so takes
away the whole like worrying about a
maintenance window or doing it on Sunday
they can roll out changes and be really
rapid and really agile in their
development cycle so even though they've
kind of made all the other environments
common to the kind of our home
environment how do they keep them in
sync well keeping them in sync is one of
the big things we've been looking at is
doing everything through policy so
policy management and that's one of the
things can
management part of anthos brings to the
table is instead of people going in and
making manual changes to customer are
two clusters why isn't it done through a
git workflow or a PR process and a peer
review and when that gets approved it
gets pushed out and not just a one
cluster you can do that too many
clusters you can also do it two clusters
on pram or in cloud the other piece it
gives them is they can add extra things
that they're concerned about like
security frameworks or if they're doing
custom sto rule sets their developers
they can start to make sure that that
framework is spread across all the
environments and then that steps up the
audit capability the compliance side so
when someone comes as how are you
managing these things they're able to
build a report and say this is all
driven from source look at the git log
and that's how we manage our
infrastructure and it's all the same
across all those environments because
the the kind of a unified config
management makes it easy to roll out
yeah even down to if someone jumps on
with elevated access and makes a manual
change to a cluster that drift that
usually happens config manager will
change it back but if you put time into
building the policies and then
developers can focus on writing code and
the security teams can focus on making
sure that that code is of the quality so
if everyone puts time into this it just
comes through a pipeline and it all
drives the quality and people in various
departments and more input most
importantly developers can focus on
developing and releasing at high
velocity and their customers just get to
focus on using the same stable
application that now they kind of feel
more confident in because the the parent
company kind of has that responsibility
of making sure it works everywhere yeah
in the end the customer just wants to be
able to you know do their job and
they're buying this software and and
they want to know that they have the
trust that it's going to be up because
you know a lot of these are billing
based application it's like the revenue
generating side of the business so
they're looking at it as a managed
service but they've got constraints that
they have to be on prem but they need to
know that when new packages or new
updates come they don't have that worry
that they're gonna have to
you know go through a lot of pain or an
outage to their customer which isn't
good obviously so as you were kind of
helping them roll out this entire
architecture
what would you say kind of the biggest
hurdle that you jumped over was I would
say just standardizing all the
configuration this particular customer
spent a lot of time putting the work in
and knowing that you know they could do
it manually to get it working once they
actually put the time into automating at
all and testing it which really pays off
in folds as you start to scale so that
was one of the challenges we took is
just getting that exact workflow they
were using in cloud and applying it and
finding the pipeline for on-prem
obviously there were some security
restrictions around networking and
access we had to deploy an on-prem
registry and find a way to sync all the
images down so we have that workflow so
the biggest thing is they put the time
in and we worked with them to enhance it
and then now they're paying off in folds
as they rolled this out as they move
forward to push this and scale their
business they don't have a lot of
technical debt it's all documentation is
living it's all in the git repo thanks
so much for coming in and showing us how
you actually kind of built this
architecture with this customer to
support kind of all of their own
customers yeah thanks for having us
we're really looking forward to rolling
out ant those to more customers and
getting it out in the market get anthos
ready by checking out this quick lab on
modernizing and deploying your
application with gke thanks for watching
and make sure to subscribe for more
great Google cloud platform content
we'll see you next time on stack chat
[Music]
you